[Música]
colombia sigue sin ratificar el acuerdo
de escazú un acuerdo internacional de
américa latina' en defensa del medio
ambiente a pesar de que el gobierno
firmó este tratado que busca proteger a
los activistas climáticos y mejorar la
transparencia y la información alrededor
de estos temas el trámite sigue
bloqueado en el congreso algunos
partidos conservadores y los principales
gremios empresariales se oponen a este
tratado argumentando que colombia ya
protege suficientemente al medio
ambiente y sus defensores sin embargo
las cifras dicen lo contrario según los
datos de la ong global witness colombia
es el país más peligroso del mundo para
ser defensor del medio ambiente en 2019
64 activistas defensores del territorio
fueron asesinados especialmente en zonas
donde operan grupos armados o en lugares
de macroproyectos económicos donde las
comunidades tratan de defender sus
territorios de actividades como el
narcotráfico la creciente deforestación
o la contaminación de las aguas y los
ríos
[Música]
brasil todavía no ha ratificado el
acuerdo de escazú y tampoco hay
perspectivas de que lo haga en el corto
plazo este acuerdo internacional
pretende salvaguardar la vida de los
activistas ambientales en un país
brasilia junto a colombia lidera el
ranking de los asesinatos precisamente
de esos activistas lo más curioso es que
tanto la prensa como la televisión de
brasil ignoran este asunto y como
consecuencia los brasileños desconocen
el contenido de este importante tratado
además hay que recordar que américa
latina lidera el ranking de asesinatos
de activistas medioambientales según la
ong global witness en 2019 aquí en este
continente hubo 148 asesinatos de un
total de 212
[Música]
la oficina del alto comisionado de las
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos instó al gobierno de honduras a
suscribirse al acuerdo de escazú un
instrumento que da acceso a la
información participación y justicia en
temas relacionados con el medio ambiente
a esta petición se han sumado varias
organizaciones ambientales en el país
quienes consideran inaudito que el
gobierno aún no se haya suscrito a este
convenio dado que honduras es uno de los
países más peligrosos para los
defensores del medio ambiente este
convenio se da precisamente cinco años
después del asesinato de la líder
ambientalista y mundialmente conocida y
galardonada berta cáceres según la
organización ambientalista vía campesina
sólo el año pasado fueron asesinados 12
ambientalistas en el país el último caso
se dio precisamente hace un mes cuando
fue asesinado un dirigente frente a sus
hijos
[Música]